for the first time in the storied
history of the franchise microsoft
flight simulator launched on a home
console with the release on xbox series
x and s last month reviewers and gamers
alike were blown away by how well the
stunning visuals and the depth of the
simulation translated to the console and
that's why i'm extremely honored to
welcome the head of microsoft flight
simulator york newman to the stream york
thank you for being here the last time
we met was at the xbox game showcase and
it was getting ready to come out on
consoles how did that go it went great
as you said the reaction to the xbox
contour launch was uh was really just
amazing
both from xbox gamers and from the press
they've been so gracious with their
feedback i don't know if you know but we
um flight simulator is one of the
highest rated games on xbox this year
which i think is just great validation
um that the trends that the translation
of the simulation to the console has
been has really worked well
our usage numbers are through the roof
uh we are absolutely shattering
franchise records and i can tell you
there have never been more people
playing flight simulator than right now
so it's an awesome time
that is awesome congratulations on the
launch really but
all right
i want to go to the danger zone so
what's going on with top gun there's so
much going on paris um so you and i
talked about top gun maverick earlier
the fans are super excited they saw the
f-18 they can't wait to start flying and
as you know it comes out later this year
as free dlc alongside the movie
but as the movie is still under wraps
and so are we so i can still not tell
you that much about it
but there's so much else going on even
before maverick so um
we are continuing to do our monthly big
releases that we've been doing for a
long time and next month on september
7th
we are launching
world update six and um this world
update i mean
at the beginning of the show if you
remember there was a little red plane
flying into cologne but we did that
because world update six updates that
region the region of gamescom so germany
austria and switzerland and what that
means to us is we have new aerial and
satellite images we have a new elevation
map that helps us with the mountains so
the alps actually look awesome now um we
we have new 3d cities like frankfurt and
bupatal in germany we have basel in
switzerland
we have vienna and kratz in austria and
um and those cities look just amazing
amazing they have like seven centimeters
revolution resolution and it's it's it's
awesome but but we want to celebrate the
entire region so we picked one hundred
of the most scenic places the most
famous landmarks and we call those pois
and we sort of split spread them
throughout the throughout the simulation
and um and we also added airports we did
lubeck and stuttgart in germany and
clarkenford in austria and zhang in
switzerland and um and what ties it all
together is its missions we're having
new uh
discovery flights we have new um landing
challenges and we have new um uh sort of
tours of the country so they they fly
you around all the awesome looking
places and really celebrate the beauty
of this region of earth and this this is
a celebration uh of of dark of germany
austria and switzerland i'm so happy to
be able to announce the date here at
gamescom
you know
that is really incredible all the
different regions and everything that
you're going to have in the game and the
the way that you're going to be able to
actually highlight those
yeah i think it's it's it's really cool
but you know for us it's actually not
just the region and the visuals we are
we are um we talked a lot when you when
you study aviation when you love
aviation like we do um you actually
realize that a lot of regions of earth
have a very special relationship with
flying with aviation sometimes it's you
know the first experiments with aircraft
or a famous pilot or a feat of aviation
or or like a local manufacturer so we
thought to ourselves why do we not use
these world updates to celebrate the
planes
so we're announcing a new series we call
them local legends and think about that
as planes that are
locally well known like in that region
but outside in the world not so much and
but why not use the world updates to
highlight this to bring these awesome
machines to a worldwide audience so for
world update 6 we picked a german plane
from the 1930s it's called jungkook's
u52
in germany it's actually it's lovingly
named tundra you so and you
and we think of us as sort of a digital
digital preservation so we really want
to get these planes to an extreme level
of detail we're going out of our way to
really go deep so we're doing a full
scan we take full scans of the outside
and the inside as detailed as one
millimeter which is as good as you can
as i'm getting ready to do this and then
we're working with for the junkers we
worked with band junkers who is the
grandson of the original creator of the
plane hugo yonkos and he's helping us he
had a ton of insight and materials then
we worked with an organization that is
preserving one of the last surviving
examples of the junkers so they let us
scan and take photographs and and then
we were lucky that to find a a pilot
that actually flew one of those planes
while he was still flying in the real
world and he gets he lets us know like
is the cockpit right and the sound's
right does it feel right in the air um
so we're having a blast working with
these experts to really bring these to
celebrate this plane to bring them back
to life so this is almost like you're
creating like a digital museum for
aviation inside microsoft flight
simulator yeah i mean it's basically
that it's a museum with flyable planes
so we're working with um 40 museums
around the world and it's it's honestly
one of the funnest parts of the job you
you end up working with these curators
of planes these are their babies and
they sort of see the tooth of time in
the real world sort of nagging on their
remaining planes and they're so happy
when we come in with our scanning
equipment and we're basically capturing
their planes and they know that we can
digitally preserve them in perpetuity
and we're actually giving those scans
back to the museum so they can do
something with that just and it's a
great collaboration
and we're actually not just looking back
in the history of aviation we're also
looking towards the future so i have
another announcement we are working with
a fascinating german company called
volocopter yeah and they're making a um
an evital air taxi for urban traffic
so they have a vision of the future how
can how these drone type machines
basically connect people in large cities
we're working directly with the
engineering team to make sure that we
are capturing their plane and their
aircraft perfectly in the flight
simulator and that's coming out in
november
i mean you weren't kidding when you're
saying that there's a lot going on
inside of microsoft flight simulator is
there anything else you want to share uh
yeah there's one more thing um yeah we
are i'm so happy to announce that we've
partnered with rahra that's the reno air
racing association and they every year
they put on something called the the
steel national championship airways and
we're bringing this to flight simulator
so it's this is the fastest motorsport
it's right down your alley it's the
fastest motorsport on earth and i
actually brought you a little a little
trailer to look at so race
speed
going to the danger zone baby let's go
ahead and show that
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
when fast and you know i love being in
the danger zone when is this coming out
man these these planes they fly 500
miles faster than 500 miles an hour 50
to 250 feet above the ground so you are
definitely going to be in the danger
zone i mean without going into much
detail this reno air race is actually
the largest expansion we have since we
launched on flight simulator it's not
just because we scanned all the famous
race planes of the world there's lots of
them
this is also the first time when you can
basically race against your friends and
pilots across the planet
and so a competitive multiplayer is
coming to microsoft flight simulator and
that will definitely test your pilot
skills and you ask when is it coming out
we are this is coming out this fall so
it's right around the corner
oh that is fantastic and you know i have
the need for speed so i can't wait to
get my hands on this and participate in
some of these air races awesome happy
gotcha
thank you
if going fast on the ground is more your
speed keep an eye out for extended look
at forza horizon 5 later on in the
stream we'll also talk with wasteland
3's game director about the game's next
big dlc but first if you're an xbox game
pass subscriber we have some great news
for you